UNUSUAL FOR US BUT NECESSARY
MADAM SECRETARY WE YOU CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES HERE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HERE HILL HERE HILL HERE LEYVA.
LEYVA HERE MCGUIRE MITCHELL MORE
LOCK MORE LUCK HERE ROTH SKINNER.
SKINNER HERE WIENER WILK
RESIDENT WILK HERE MINING ATKINS
HERE ATKINS HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU.
ARMS SO AS WE GO TO THE AGENDA I
JUST WANT.
TO QUICKLY TALK ABOUT THE
PURPOSE OF THE MEETING IS SO IN
THE BEGINNING OF EVERY SESSION
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE MUST
ESTABLISH THE CHAIR AND CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER OF THE
COMMITTEE PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE.
FORTY ADDITIONALLY THE COMMITTEE
MUST APPROVE THE PRESS CONTROL
CREDENTIALS FOR THE REGULAR
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE OF EACH HOUSE
MEET SEPARATELY TO CONSIDER
THESE ACTIONS.
AND IF THE MAJORITY OF MEMBERS
OF THE SEPARATE MEETINGS VOTE IN
FAVOR OF THE ACTIONS THE ACTIONS
WILL BE APPROVED.
SO I WANTED TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT
OF OVERVIEW OF WHAT THIS IS IN
LINE WITH THE RULES.
AS WE ADD TAKE UP THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS TO A POINT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY AS
CHAIR OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION.
APPOINT DEBRA GRAVERT AS THE
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER OF
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND THEN
AGAIN AS I STATED --
THREE WOULD BE TO APPROVE THE
PRESS CREDENTIALS FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION [inaudible]
SO -- THANK
YOU.
MISTER HERTZBERG FIVE MAN
SECRETARY WE'VE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
SENATORS [inaudible]
SENATORS BATES.
AIDS AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL MORE LOCK.
MORE LUCK I'D ROTH SKINNER
SKINNER AYE WIENER WILK HIGH
WILK AYE MINING.
MONNING AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS I
WE HAVE TEN VOTE I BELIEVE MADAM
SECRETARY SO THAT MOTION OUR
PASSES.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS WHO WERE HERE SO
PROMPTLY --
THAT WE CAN GET THAT DONE IN
LESS THAN FIVE MINUTES OUR DUTY
HAS BEEN DONE AS THE CONTENT
SENATE CONTENTION OF THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE SO WITH THAT
[inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
IS IT -- IS
THERE POSSIBILITY THERE ARE
OTHER.
YES WE CAN WE CAN NOT TAKE THAT
ITEM UP.
AND DO SO --
SO WE TO MY COLLEAGUES --
WE ARE ADJOURNED.
AT WE WILL TAKE A FEW MINUTES
BEFORE WE RE ADJUST AND CONVENE
AS THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR OUR
REGULARLY SCHEDULED.
MEETING